first question for you guys of all the
reactions that you saw to Scream 5 which
reaction would you say influenced what
we see the most in Scream sex oh wow
great questions
um
I don't I don't know if there's a
specific reaction can you think of one I
mean I would say it's a good question
though um but I think us and Guy and
Jamie we approach it as fans and like
what would we want to see
and so in a way it's a reaction to our
own reaction which is also a fan
reaction
yeah but we're I mean we're definitely
aware of like the noise good and bad you
know in that like you you have to be I
feel like to to step into something that
is so self-referential and and So Meta
we have to have our antennas up for that
stuff and I think that we definitely we
learned a ton on five
um and I think
all of that is is deployed in sex I'll
turn that in to you guys now given
everything you guys experienced as fans
even watching your own film with five
what became the top priority to execute
in screen sex to surprise ourselves yeah
I like that I think it was such a
surprise it was such a surprise to have
scream come back to be involved in it
um and I think we just knew that for as
warm and comforting and as homage as the
last one was we had to we had to take a
really hard left turn for the next one
uh just to keep ourselves interested
right to to keep ourselves engaged and
surprised and I think that's um that's
always been the compass like what what
is thrilling and fun and exciting to us
and hopefully that you know the people
love the same thing that Compass is
pointing in the right direction I like
it so I was reading the production notes
and it has a whole lot about how you
guys wanted this movie to have some of
the most brutal attack and kill seek
sequences of the franchise in it so it
was making me curious before making
Scream Six what did you both deem the
most brutal sequence of the franchise
the thing that became the one to top I
feel like uh the Gale Dewey
sound booth yeah pizza so you know that
whole shebang they caught the police car
climbing over goes like yeah like that's
been attacking of obstacles one on top
of another on top of another was I think
the thing that we've always really
thought defined the the the sequences in
the screen franchise and New York was
just a perfect there's so many
ingredients to to play with here I
didn't expect you guys to name drop
those two scenes but I respect those
choices this is gonna be a little bit of
a difficult one to answer while avoiding
spoilers but just to tease this a little
can you guys kind of hint at how the
physicality of ghost-based changes in
this movie given the identity of the
killer what is something specific to
scream six Ghostface that we don't see
in any other scream film he doesn't trip
over any couches yes he jumps over some
he's not that clumsy there's a little
there's a little of the you know we love
the kind of the goofy side of it but uh
there's less of that in this it's also I
think we're saying that you know Max who
was the stunt man is Ghost Face on this
time he just had a different presence
and we really leaned into that like I
think it really helped Define that
character in a lot of ways for this one
yeah and we built we built the sets and
we kind of conceived of the sequences so
that
um everyone could go at a hundred
percent right like the things could
break the way that they you see them
break in the movie doors get smashed
like everything was everyone was using
their full physicality the entire time
and it I think it makes for like a
really visceral
scary
series of sequences that it does I'm
only behaving and leaving right now
because I get to interrogate the two of
you tomorrow with like an enormous list
of spoiler questions and I cannot wait
oh great
congratulations I will see you soon
we'll see you tomorrow see you soon